why did some of these guys
agree to sit down with you what is the
call for them to say yeah i'll sit down
with john what call came before you
showed up
they would usually get a call from the
world bank maybe the secretary of state
of the united states somebody's saying
you know this is this this this man's
passing through your country and would
like to arrange a meeting to you and
talk about what we might do to help your
country that's the script that's the
script something like that yes and that
phone call is made to who to to the
president or to his chief of staff or
god whoever sets up such meetings but it
would probably end up in his hands and
torrijos
so he was an interesting guy you know
panama was a very charismatic party
animal loved to you know loved his
cigars and his and his rum and
barbecues you know i got to know him
very well because he was very
charismatic that way very flamboyant or
not flamboyant just party yes
flamboyance
this is in the 70s
yes this is before noriega and
everything that happened with that yes
right yeah noriega came after that so
this is during the negotiations for the
panama canal tree you got it and it was
it was carter and and torrijos
and you know tariq has got pretty much
what he wanted in that
and he became a hero throughout the
third what we call the third i like to
call the
the the the lower income countries if
you want to call it that
um
he became a hero and so he became very
dangerous so the united states really
wanted to bring him under control so i
was sent down to reign him in
and he wouldn't be reigned in he was he
had tremendous integrity
and a big ear
also you know he liked to be on the
front page and and he liked to be known
as as david facing goliath you know his
little country underdog mentality total
you know very very small country very
small population but it had the canal
and and he became very very well known
throughout the world as a guy who would
stand up
so when you spoke to him and you you use
the same protocol that you use with you
know
others in the past
it wasn't effective with this guy when
he spoke to him he just wasn't going to
budge and he openly would tell you he
what did he tell you openly when you
guys spoke
well he was the one that really helped
me understand what we were truly doing
he pointed out to me something and i'll
use today's numbers
but he in those days it was similar
he today if three
three americans own as much wealth as
half the united states population right
and if those three americans made ten
percent on their assets last year and
and half the country lost three percent
and everybody'll stay the same we'd show
a growth of something close to four
percent so it would look like the whole
country prospered when in fact only
three people prospered half stayed the
same and
half lost three percent and tori has
pointed that out to me and so that's
true in the united states with three
people and as much as 50 imagine what
it's like where three people own not as
much as 95 which is true in a lot of
these countries torrijos pointed out to
me he said you know these numbers that
you're throwing around the gdp it's
totally rigged in favor of the rich
you're not helping the poor people with
any of these countries
uh and so he he was one of the people
that really helped me have to face the
truth of what i was doing and at the
same time you know one time he took me
out on this yacht he didn't he didn't
own the yacht but he had a lot of he fit
the friends he was always out on these
yachts you know we're on this yacht
we're drinking uh
all kinds of you know rum drinks and
disease we're surrounded by these
beautiful bikini-clad ladies uh sounds
horrible just awful you would have hated
it yeah yeah
you know i just see ladies yeah horrible
patrick i just saw a video of you on a
boat as you were arriving here in
florida deciding to come here it was
kind of like that except you were
surrounded by all these guys
don't get me started on that john
okay so you're you're having this drink
with him you're on the eye if you're
having a conversation with him what's he
telling he has to be on the back he
offers me a cigar he says hey john why
don't you come work for me
you won't make nearly as much money but
you'll have a lot more fun and you'll
feel really good about what you're doing
for the world
he tried to recruit you
yeah for him yeah
i didn't i wish i you know i know i
don't wish i had he you know he i think
he got assassinated he's you know it's
never been proven but his plane went
down very his private plane in a very uh
suspicious under various
what was the thing called it was a name
for it you know like the
project something that uh uh united
fruit or was that more guatemala no that
was more guatemala
with our benz yeah yeah so with him
you know you said something about when
he got on the plane
right after the whole deal he did with
carter there was a tape recorder that
went in and the tape recorder blew up
has that been verified that was a tape
recorder no no
when he got on the when he got on the
plane
uh somebody handed him a tape recorder
and uh that's the suspicion is that it
was a bomb but you know
when a plane blows up there's no smoking
gun because it blows up too and just
three months before less than three
months before that jaime roald dose the
president of ecuador who also stood up
to me did not accept the deals he i did
i wasn't as friendly with him he was
loved by the way he was loved and adored
he wasn't like
he was loved and authority and
democratically elected yeah for the
first democratic elected president in
ecuador in a number of years
uh he wasn't as as as warm and fuzzy and
friendly as as torijo so i never got to
know him personally the way i did terry
house
but so he he died in this plane crash
in may
and uh in 1981 and uh torrijos met with
his family after that and he said you
know my my brother jaime was just
assassinated by the cia
and again that was never proven but
there was a suspicion
and they said you know i'll probably
probably be next but don't worry because
i've signed the the panama canal treaty
with carter so i've accomplished what i
really came here to accomplish and less
than three months later exactly almost
the same thing happened to him so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]